British restaurants will want to laugh
in stock not anymore today we have some
of the most exciting restaurants in the
world but which are the best and what
are the restaurants that you really love
I asked you and the response was amazing
we had over 12 000 nominations for
restaurants all over the UK
together we're the best restaurant team
I've chosen the best and tonight my two
favorite restaurants will be going Head
to Head they may be good but do they
have what it takes to go right to the
top
thank you
over the last six months my team and I
have been all over the country checking
out your best restaurant nominations
and tonight my search continues with
another of the UK's favorite cuisines
Thai
[Music]
over the last 10 years Thai food has
taken Britain by storm even the pubs are
doing it now but really top-notch
authentic Thai restaurants are so hard
to find a couple times please
I've eaten some great restaurants in
Thailand and I know that's secret to
authentic Thai food it's all about
getting that balance right between the
Sweet Bitter hot sour and salty flavors
tonight's contenders I'm gonna have to
be at the top of the game to impress me
from hundreds of Thai nominations I've
hand-picked my top two to go head to
head for a place in the semi-finals
[Applause]
from Saint Andrews Scotland's golfing
Capital
it's Nam Jim
I just love to show you know how good
Thai food is I just very proud
fighting it out with a colossal Thai
restaurant from the heart of London
mango tree
I'm always spider I don't need Gordon's
sticker rocket up my ass I'm there I'm
ready
namjim and the mango tree will be
battling to prove they have what it
takes to be my best Thai restaurant
the first of three grueling challenges
I've dispatched 30 fervent Foodies
who'll descend on each restaurant in
turn and order on Mass
it's bonnis and Andrews
this town is not only famous for his
golf venue but also Nam Jim an amazing
Thai restaurant it's run by dynamic duo
husband and wife Sandy and B and they
Pride themselves on cooking authentic
Thai Cuisine today I'm expecting nothing
less than a hole in one
[Music]
the only Scott in the village
the first and only Thai restaurant in
Saint Andrews Nam Jim's charm and
authentic Cuisine has taken the tan by
storm
it's simple but perfect
determined to wow the locals bees even
created an inspired signature dish using
Scotland's National Fair
I guess
very spicing it doesn't actually taste
like haggis it tastes like pork doesn't
it
that's delicious
what I love most about this place is
their chef B she's bursting with energy
she's happy in her cooking her staff are
happy and it shows in the food
amazingly but he had never cooked
professionally until she and her husband
Sandy open Nam gym eight years ago
successful businesses all the detail and
we kind of try and be the best we can be
we use the best ingredients from
Thailand great service we just try and
do everything as good as it can be don't
we this is one the restaurants a huge
following of Celebrity Golf fans
this is my hold of them that's a Tiger
Woods's mother Mr Sean Connery here Mr
Samuel Jackson he just said thank you
very much your food is wonderful I was
so proud
now being Sandy's hard-fought reputation
is about to be tested to its limits
a coach full of hungry diners are just
around the corner all 30 of them will
expect a faultless meal in just two
hours
[Music]
gonna be over everything not just the
dining room but in the kitchen as well
thank you and as you know I miss nothing
I'll be spotting everything
manager Sandy is in charge of keeping
all my 30 diners happy
Haney's team must explain B's unique
Thai Dishes one of the house Specialties
is the Thai Scottish haggis we can also
make that with a vegetarian haggis which
is essentially pulses and nuts and
oatmeal
I think the orders are starting to roll
now yeah yeah as well as the Haggis bees
menu includes vegetarian jungle Curry
and Tamarind duck with Pak choy
two lamp to prawns
as fast as front of house send the
orders through b and her efficient type
Brigade are knocking out amazing food
it's quick it's not a long-winded style
of cooking it's done in a very fresh and
sort of Rapid Way
[Music]
Sandy the only Brit on the team is the
all-important link between the dining
room and the kitchen
are you at your weakest in here when
they're speaking fluent child I just
kind of ignore what they're talking
about and I can see kind of what they're
doing more than I think
they've been working together for so
long it's a really well-awiled machine
it's not a race to me the standards far
more important you know okay
if the starters are anything to go by
the standards don't seem to be a problem
that's like I guess I've never tested
it's exceptional it's absolutely
beautiful
Brigade are on fire but at this hectic
pace it's vital that every member of the
team is on top of every detail
s
Sandy stop stop stop coconut cream
there's no coconut cream on there
you're taking dishes she doesn't know
who's gone
one lamb Cutlass as well guys and that's
all the start has done for everybody
then
Sandy thinks all the starters are out
but a quick scan of the dining room
reveals he's missed a whole table
however
the spicy haggis
just front of house boss Sandy should be
all over this so that's so that's all
gone
no that's all gone really yes
C3 they've got their food so it smells
nice can't taste the way it smells nice
okay no problem the two c3s as opposed
to C2 yeah
okay enjoy at last the missing table get
their food
look for the mains
Sandy's front of house team see more and
more disorientated we've got more
waiters in here now than we have chefs
[Music]
more lamps here
do you know where you're going Sandy
Sandy looks a little bit sort of lost
there yeah you know when he comes in a
little bit Yeah pressure like this it's
just like you like to be out of the way
so you handle pressure better than he
does
despite his confusion
send desserts out with 45 minutes to
spare
and it's soon clear how he's done it
it's a bit weird she's eating her
dessert while I'm having my main course
I don't think we expected that when we
ordered it you know when he ordered I
thought I'd be watching it started and
then we'd have our meal together sure
it's best to serve a starter yeah Gap
main course Gap and then desserts we
thought rather than somebody sit there
eating while the partner has nothing for
20 minutes it was less rude for somebody
to be eating at the same time I know
that's personally how I would prefer it
it doesn't make sense
no I agree we haven't seen it so far in
the competition
[Music]
okay last table got out guys
[Applause]
today being a kitchen team really have
scored a hole in one
I went for the Thai vegetarian hikers
which was really Exquisite the food was
fantastic start to finish it was
delicious really knock the socks off
after the food it really my birthday was
good it's worth waiting for yeah pretty
much it with such fantastic food the
wheat link here is clearly front of
house
I've spoken to the diners and not
everybody enjoyed having their dessert
and the main course at the same time
dessert is a sort of sweet Grand Finale
not to be eaten opposite a duck
the Saving Grace today is that everyone
loved the food that's for me the most
important tine up get the service as
good as the food
in 99 of the way there
[Music]
now I'm Jim's heavyweight Rivals from
London are up against the robes the
thighs roll yeah it's the same table
oh dear and one of my undercover diners
cop set I'm not paying for it oh yeah
call the police oh my God
foreign
hit squad of 30 diners are on their way
to the second Thai restaurant battling
for a semi-final place in my Nationwide
competition
just a stone's throw from Buckingham
Palace is one of the most popular Thai
restaurants in the capital it's mango
tree hello
[Music]
has been front of house manager of this
huge 160 seat restaurant since it opened
10 years ago
it's my baby this is my life my
inspiration even the kitchen is huge as
well how are you very nice to meet you
so nice to see a Englishman heading a
Thai Kitchen
where you from I'm Thailand you're from
Thailand thank God for that
HF Mark's passion for Asian Cuisine led
him to work in Vietnamese and Japanese
kitchens before coming to the mango tree
what we're trying to create is that
essence of the Thai street food served
in an eloquent way
his accomplished take on Thai Cuisine
attracts 350 diners a night on a busy
weekend
it's one of my favorite restaurants
probably in London you feel like you're
in a five-star restaurant I really enjoy
coming here it's one of those places
that you can really trust
[Music]
for Mark controlling such a vast
operation is made Harder by a less than
ideal restaurant layout
with the kitchen and dining room on
different floors all the food is sent by
Lyft
[Music]
please
don't get nervous with all these air
pieces and it's like someone from the
secret police
coordinate food and service the staff
use radio headsets and if all else fails
there's always the phone yeah it's
coming right now when a customer happy
when does
[Music]
Mars revered food this huge restaurant
should find my first test at Doddle
[Music]
struggle with my coachload of 30 diners
arriving and ordering all at once
they'll expect every dish to be cooked
to perfection
[Music]
I want my diners to leave tonight you
know on cloud nine I want their jaws on
the floor really push it out yeah and
good luck
we got a new order two me income one
chicken satay we're just gonna do what
we do best and that's the quality and
the consistency of the food you don't
want to be complacent if there's dirty
Pad Thai there'll be 30 great Pad Thai
it's that simple
Mark has hand-picked a small selection
of his most popular dishes for my guests
tonight
including shrimp tom yum chicken satay
and tiger prawn pad thai
he's taking these Thai Classics to a new
level of sophistication with truly
authentic flavors and exquisite
presentation but upstairs in front of
house I discovered when he's made a big
mistake with his menu
or vegetarian option we can speak to
Chef they can prepare whatever you like
I think we actually would like speak to
the manager
and just tell me an option
completely unacceptable can I help you
man
um
I do apologize for this time but all of
the dish in here can be substituted to
vegetarian that's not a problem that's
all you don't need to worry about it
Knox professionalism has calmed a
potential mutiny
meanwhile the Fisher meat eaters are
loving the starters beautiful flavors
complement each other
amazing I would definitely recommend
but there's a serious problem with one
Diner's chicken satay the chicken cooked
it seems quite fleshy inside and quite
big it's absolutely yeah sorry that's
excuse me
that will take another five ten minutes
[Music]
you don't expect it from the top
restaurant to ask for my food to be sent
back to the kitchen new order one
chicken satay well done a raw you'll eat
them
both the chicken satay starter and the
baby chicken main course are half cooked
free service and finished off to order
by commie Chef Nielsen on this occasion
he's got it badly wrong if your part
Cooks the chicken you won't expect it to
go out pink no what'd you get that down
the park it's very annoying when we're
dealing with the people that we are
dealing with tonight
no excuse for it Mark's been quick to
send up a replacement dish but I want to
see how well this lift system works
in my restaurant I can bark orders at my
waiters over the past
but here every dish that leaves the
kitchen must travel up two flights of
stairs by dumb waiter to Mikey it's his
job to send the food to the right table
what table is that
what they should tell you what table it
is before they send the [__] thing
though yeah I actually don't know never
what is coming in the late I can only
guess seeing the food and carry it to
the ticket okay no he's selling food but
no one's told him what table in terms of
you haven't got the tickets for this one
yeah so it's just sat there diet please
yeah it's always like this yeah I
thought man that's for 30. you imagine
like we've got 300
.
everything in the lift send it
and service ramps up the system is
falling apart
oh this is the main it is yes we wait
while they finish the start and then you
bring our main meal oh yeah
[Music]
but most of the mistakes are picked up
by the waiting staff before they hit the
dining room
what's wrong with that
he sent out wrong so I need I need this
instead
and was that what is this Chevrolet it's
not missing
uh oh I don't got a ticket for a guyang
uh but I go what table is it
send it down to you
[Music]
this is crazy
what a mess lots of great food go
nowhere fast oh
they got the main cause already
that lift is busier than [__] Paris
Hilton's knickers yes huh
damn this lift to be a nemesis you ever
give an absolute total pain in the ass
he doesn't know what he's sending up
there it leaves Harry macular it goes up
in the lift they grab it out it pisses
down the side those diners are going to
get pissed off for that which I mean
this thing is nothing short of a miracle
that all 30 diners eventually received
the correct food
it's beautiful
worth waiting for
I'm in heaven I'm in heaven but
seems once again this table's got a
problem with their food
yeah
after the earlier cock-up with the
undercooked chicken starter unbelievably
it's happened again
so let me just take it back I'm always
afraid
of course could kill you yes
now we're looking
just the yeah it's on the bone just in
the bone [__]
damn
come back walk
Mark is on the war path
how's it possible huh you're not
checking any of them
I mean look you're [__] pre-cooking
them
is it that hard
nobody wants to eat raw chicken you
huh
to my horror the true scale of the
chicken scandal is only just unfolding
it's definitely raw the other bits were
okay but yeah just this one that piece
the same again he also had it now what I
could come back
[Music]
two more portions of grilled chicken so
they take a make sure it's well done
this time what's wrong with that one
same table same table yeah 36. he's
right I think yeah the thighs roll yeah
this is the last thing I expected from
this incredible restaurant
HF Mark looks as shocked as me
this is what we're talking about quality
and the consistency
I'm the one who looks the crap
huh
we're supplying there's two two tables
that kind of messed it up
[Music]
fingers crossed for this one
this piece is okay
it's stunning it's really really good
it's it's a very big difference from the
last place I got
it
it's a credit to knock on the front of
house team that the majority of my
diners seem unaffected by the chaos
really really nice really tasty the
service is amazing to stay really really
good they're really accommodating when I
said that I didn't like spicy food and
stuff the pad thai was really really
nice and Mild
right
because there was a problem with the
menu and the vegetarian our particular
waiter has been absolutely wonderful
with us really attentive it took a great
interest into our experience here at the
mango tree in the end most of my diners
seem happy
but for Mark it's been one of the
toughest nights of his career uh right
where should we start
I know what you're capable of you don't
have to read the comments to why this
Russian is in this competition and the
support you've got from customers is
phenomenal totally then my diners arrive
and unfortunately they haven't had that
same experience that's where it hurts
for me
come back
and come back strong absolutely
[Music]
nice good night
let me throw that away and fight all the
way sick of looking at it
every time something isn't right you
know I do take it very personally it's
no reflection that our team can't cook
but situations do happen sometimes it's
how you Rectify them is the most
important thing and and hopefully they
um they don't happen again
[Music]
now I'm Jim and the mango tree have
survived the coast trip now I want to
meet up to review their performances
also they think
they have no idea of being spying on
them with the help of undercover diners
who've been filming secretly
Simon Davis is a professional secret
diner with an Eagle Eye for weak spots
in restaurant food and service
Sarah Durden Robertson is a top food
consultant who's been expertly
dissecting menus food and service for
years I've asked them both to be
demanding to see how the restaurants
respond
it's a bit too spicy for me could I
order the chicken I'd really like to
have that
but I ordered this one
first up is nam Jim
and I'm about to show them a friend of
house Fiasco that no one is prepared for
unknown to both of you I sent in a
secret Diner
that's very cool and this is what he saw
good evening how are you have you got a
table book to the name of Duncan
Ah that's the Thai haggis
thank you very much
that hang is it's a creative idea to
farm it's invented the spice levels
perfectly pitched
it's the sort of thing that could set
this restaurant a cart from other Thai
restaurants in the country absolutely
loved it and that kind of wow factor my
God could I try glass of the white Thai
wine
oh do you can I just try a little bit
fast
I know I've never had Thai wine before I
don't know what it's going to be like if
you don't like it you know what am I
going to do with the bottle
it means you have to have it what if
it's not very nice wine I won't want to
drink it wow that's not how we often
want services
Sunday
no that's a bit of a shock to me yeah
okay if you don't like it you don't have
to have it okay yeah
[Music]
I don't do like that I don't think I do
like that actually yeah I
know but I told you that if I didn't
like it I wouldn't have it
can't wait to actually looked looked at
me and went
he behave like that if you were there
Sunday
I think not what he's more likely to do
would be probably to come and ask
what to do about the situation damn it's
not ideal it is appalling
I'm just shocked in all honesty
call the police
basically I told you before if I have to
hold on a minute I asked for a glass of
Thai wine uh okay are you gonna let me
speak okay and you give me the evil eye
and you say to me I'm gonna you have to
pay for that wine and then and then you
say to me if you don't pay for that one
I'm gonna go and call the police
search you call that decent service dude
I'll pay for it but I mean that's just
absurd
that ranks as about the most aggressive
service I've ever seen in my life oh my
God
I'll call the police
I'm lost for words
incredible
what I would love to happen is I put out
the knowledge Branch to the manager he
takes it we kind of kiss and make up
figuratively speaking excuse me hi there
hi there
um what's happening with the [__] up
lines to be honest I'm not going to
charge you for a place but I have to
chat you have places okay all right I
didn't you know I did all this business
with the police I thought it was very
strange
the only thing I can think
I see in his face he knew you shouldn't
threat to call the police how does it
make you feel when you see that style of
service been running your business yeah
on both shocked very embarrassed and uh
not more than a little bit angry overall
that's been a very energizing experience
on many levels I'm enthusiastic and
excited about the quality of the food
the service has been smiling and
purchase apart from the one blip
and I'm leaving here thinking I would
definitely come back here and I would
tell people about it and they're the two
things that when you're a restaurant
owner you really want your diners to
leave
some night you have well it will be
corrected that will never happen again
obviously the gentleman has Has Come
Away with a decent experience apart from
that one lip as he called it but it to
be honest it's difficult for me to look
beyond that blip
everything you did was perfect
[Music]
uh it's I'm I'm upset and I think it's a
combination of
being very excited and very happy and
then one minute and then go in the
complete opposite end of the spectrum
the next and you know so at the minute I
think I'm just a little bit lost for
words I'm just very
you know been angry for someone to point
out of this you know because of the best
service and then the thing it's not it's
not that not what we want our customers
come first and everything
I hope we haven't blown our chances
within the competition
[Music]
um
we're gonna have to work hard
[Music]
next the chefs feel the heat in their
final battle at my Flagship restrooms
what's wrong with that so the chicken is
undercooked [__]
tonight two amazing restaurants are
going head to head in a competition to
find my best restaurant in Britain
[Applause]
now it's the turn of London's Thai
culinary giant mango tree to get the Spy
treatment
how are you are you well good welcome
we've actually been tested twice
because since I've left the mango tree I
sent in
my secret Diners right yeah and here's
what they saw
on the coach trip head chef Mark was
crestfallen when undercooked chicken was
sent back to the kitchen
manager knock supervision kept them on
side
but how do they do when I'm not watching
we've got a small plank on my table
that is filthy
they've got all these plastic white
clean covers but they never wipe them
clean it's got food cakes all over it
it's revolting
nothing
more
disappointing first touch of the menu
dirty
that glass noodle salad is so spicy
is there any way I could have it but
just a bit less spicy I would say thank
you thank you wow
wow fantastic that was really quick as
well they've brought some of the sauce
separately in case I want to control my
own measure that's exactly what you
should do exactly uh well handled great
when somebody says they want something a
certain way we don't understand what
they're less spicy is sure so it gives
them the opportunity to to do that
themselves well it was under brilliantly
it's not very relaxing
on the back tables pulling this serving
mats from under the cutlery so every
table he does
every time they do it I feel like I've
overstayed my work and they're trying to
clear the tables would you please get
out now
I feel like saying I'm terribly sorry am
I in your way
what a shame when they feel that awkward
and the noise is ridiculous especially
when you're trying to eat dinner
food what's
complained about a couple of things sent
them back and they completely dealt with
it
but their customer care is pretty
shockingly bad it's a bizarre place it's
neither one thing nor the other they
care and they don't care
uh
food
delicious second to none but that
attention detail with a service it has
to be worked out for everybody you
forget that sometimes when you're doing
such big numbers
so don't take it personally take it
professionally absolutely
[Music]
it was interesting yeah it was a bit of
an eye-opener what we saw on the film it
is
customer I I would I would say the same
so um very disappointed I don't feel let
down by the service because we are the
team we take the Pats on the back
together but we take the knocks together
as well and we will fix it there is more
to the competition and we don't want
this to be the end for us
both restaurants have been left reeling
by these Revelations but there's still
everything to play for
for their final battle and bringing the
chefs face to face in my Flagship
restaurant
I've challenged each Chef to create one
amazing dish for 20 guests but to
guarantee a place in the semi-finals
will have to be the finest dish of their
lives
what happened to me here it's dream so
we're both very very proud
if we win that would be
brilliant it was our customers that have
put us where we are it speaks volumes
that they're proud of what we're doing
everything is focused on today in
winning
right
just one two
twenty stunning dishes make them taste
absolutely delicious create that level
of perfection sadly one of you believe
in competition and one of you will be
going through to semi-final make sure
it's you good luck yeah thank you
both freshers will be attempting to
impress me with a dish made from chicken
the perfect meat to complement the heady
aromatic herbs and spices used in Thai
cooking both Omega Tree and Nam gym have
had their ups and downs and I'm hoping
that they put all that aside and they
focus on those 20 dishes and use that as
they come back
outside a dining room full of VIPs all
with a passion for Thai food will help
me judge both dishes tonight
[Music]
cookery writer oi cheap chai Sarah and
one of my all-time favorite Thai chefs
Patria wearapan all the front of house
teams can do is wait and Hope
unorder two covers away Table Three the
mango tree two baby chicken yes chef
for mango tree head chef Mark is
sticking his neck out with a new complex
dish made from the baby chickens that
almost flawed him on the coach trip he
was gutted when undercooked chicken was
sent out three times
cooked enough I just hope he knows what
he's doing today I'm happy with that
oh lovely flavor beautiful smell you're
quite fond of baby chicken aren't you I
am we've changed it from obviously when
we've done it in the restaurant we've
learned from our mistakes of um you know
making sure it Cooks it's why I wanted
to do it because I'm not going to run
away from anything good
very bold to put that baby chicken back
on the menu again Mark's exposed it's
only two of them him or not so it's pure
Focus
Phenom gym I'm worried that b is still
shaken by my secret Diner's bombshell
I don't want this to affect the quality
of our dish
first of all I want to clear something
really important that's gone the wine I
want you to set that completely behind
you today is about you and your food and
then show me that passion yeah
tonight be sticking to what she does
best authentic food packed with flavor
marinated chicken with pan-fried oyster
mushrooms and a Punchy basil puree but
to elevate this dish to my restaurant's
three Mission star standards she needs
to be completely on the ball
[Music]
the food's hanging around too long
B is making simple mistakes right now
please no I'm Jim two chickens yeah
you're not even listening to me after
that is two more not four more you've
got four chicken in there okay so do you
want to take two chicken outs
this is not all right after this it's
only two more okay you've got four in
the pan so why don't you take two outs
before
B's lack of focus is beginning to worry
me I need to see her really step up to
the Mark he's doing okay
just messy at the moment I'm rushing
let's focus on the service V yeah let's
focus on these yeah
the she's had a rocky ride up into the
stage I want that to be put behind her
and just focus on the 20 plates and come
back but come back strong
service police level six as quick as you
can pleasure thank you I'm so nervous
about me me getting there
let's go let's go let's go let's go it's
been a struggle but she's got the food
out
so this place is much better yeah
well done beat good job thank you go
please
enjoy the chicken is very subtle and the
sauce is beautiful it's lovely Aroma but
presentation I'm not quite I'm quite
confident I thought bees dish was
excellent
after his chicken disaster Mark has
determined every piece will be cooked to
Perfection today
how long please mark four portions table
two in three minutes his final touch is
to grill it to turn the skin a delicious
golden brown Mark your dishes it's
supposed to be crispy the skin I don't
want it to come across as burn good
first table table five please yeah happy
with that Mark no no what is that
fragrance Jasmine yeah very nice Mark
has gone the extra mile and his food
looks wonderful let's go play double
five thank you
mango tree
it looks beautiful
I'm happy I'm so happy I'm so exciting
about it from the mango tree you can see
from my face this is wow factor for me
the finishing line is within sight when
the unthinkable happens
excuse me
um I'm just a bit disappointed because
actually as you can see this is not
really cooked
let me show it to the chef okay so thank
you very much let me take it away for
you
[Music]
chicken is undercooked where's it under
oh [__] it
is not even coming off the bone there
you see it clear as day [__] me
[__]
damn I'm so pissed off putting chicken
comes back again and if there was ever a
time not to serve it it's right now not
good enough four more Mark please how
long just give me times I can tell the
dining room three minutes three minutes
for table one please tell Rob don't
worry about the leg yeah [__] the leg
pretty pissed off
makes me eat my own words I'm not happy
one pleasure
even I could never have guessed servers
would end like this for mango tree
[Music]
it's been a challenging night for
everyone
but it's time to find out what my diners
thought of both dishes starting with
mango tree
let's talk chicken well ours wasn't
cooked no well that was a ridiculous
mistake yeah my apologies it just it
wasn't even leaving the bone was it it
was probably still clucking
fortunately not all my diners had the
same experience
is looked great when it came yes and
when we tasted it the herbs go right
through it better than sex
I prefer the mango tree because I love
the chicken on the bone it kept it
really moist very very tasty and the
broth with it just worked loved it all I
had to go for 19. because I like this so
so much it's beautifully marinated
subtle and then you got the sauces
complement the combination
yes and the chicken is lovely but the
rice is with too much water I mean you
know your rice
I'm sorry
now I face a very difficult Choice which
one of these two restaurants should go
through to the semi-finals
for Gordon Ramsey to say you're the best
that is mean a lot
I would never forget it neither
restaurant has been without fault but
even good restaurants have their bad
days
I'm obviously hoping that the other 19
dishes make a bigger impact and
impression than the one but can I
forgive Mark for undercooking chicken
again
my two Top Thai contenders Nam Jim and
mango tree have completed a nail biting
service in my Flagship restaurant
both chefs are produced an incredible
dish but both have fallen short of
perfection
now I have to choose which restaurant is
truly deserving of a place in the
semi-final but first I need to make my
own judgment on both dishes
[Music]
now I'm Jim it looks slightly clumsy
chicken's delicious it's got that nice
crisp texture of the outside you spare
that sauce on top of that chicken the
whole thing just comes alive not
eye-catching but mouth-watering and
taste
mango tree have gone the extra mile and
it looks like it's been done with great
finesse Flair lovely
the broth is almost like a sort of Tom
Young Gun it's like two dishes in one
rice soft fluffy and Incredibly fragrant
nice little spray at the end with that
Jasmine really nice chicken's delicious
but I'm just slightly nervous about that
soft chewy skin should be crispy
[Applause]
two remarkable Thai restaurants
but only one can continue through to the
next round
right I brought both Russians here to
give you an opportunity a unique
opportunity to really cook like you've
never cooked before
now I'm Jim I saw the dish
it didn't look the most appetizing
having been to your restaurant and seen
the style
in which you've delivered food it was a
little bit of a surprise to see
something so basic as that I tasted the
chicken and bang it was just yeah it was
amazing
however at this stage in the competition
this round is not one on a single dish
namjim secret diners never experienced
food like that absolutely love that food
haggis in a Thai restaurant
doesn't even sound right
but for you to turn into something that
good
very few Russians can do that anywhere
mango tree
the fascinating thing with Yuma is
you're not even you're not even from
Thailand you seem to have this magic
with Thai Cuisine that is a is a gift
and my mango tree's at its best is
untouchable sent in a secret Diner
absolutely blown away with that food I
mean really
blown away with that food
to do the Busan again at this stage in
the competition I admire the balls
[Music]
it was sweet
it was delicious and authentic how could
I criticize that how could I look at
that dish and tell you how to do it
better
I didn't have to for the first time this
competition I just came back
[Music]
you've left with a very tough decision
the restaurant going through to the
semi-final is
[Music]
Nam Jim congratulations
well done yes
with your touch and the amount of
experience you have with Thai Cuisine I
know you've got more coming very
disappointed you know I'm sorry for
letting odd and north and the team and
our customers down but you know that's
the way it goes you know I wish Nam Jim
all the luck but
I'm pretty pissed off at the moment
someone never told me before I'm I'm
good and I'm into this competition so
it's meant so much for me it's a bit
mind-boggling for us we're all very very
proud and a little bit shocked and
stunned I think
I'm so happy
[Music]
what an amazing day and two great
Russians I'll be sorry to say goodbye to
Mango Tree but the same hand we've
opened the door to something quite
magical in St Andrews because they are a
force to be reckoned with but for Nam
gym now the competition really starts
because the next stage of this
competition it's gonna be even tougher
which restaurants will be fighting for a
place in the semi-final so on the plate
an ambitious Chef running his own
version of Versailles so you can sit
down and be treated like a king for a
night takes on a gallic gastronome
jumping a peasant revolution in
Edinburgh I'm not looking for Kings I'm
cooking for simple guys like me for
country boys but only one will make it
through to the next round and win the
chance to become my best restaurant
this is it the battle of the French good
luck
[Music]
British restaurants will want to laugh
in stock not anymore today we have some
of the most exciting restaurants in the
world but which are the best and what
are the restaurants that you really love
I asked you and the response was amazing
we had over 12 000 nominations for
restaurants all over the UK
together with the best restaurant team
I've chosen the best and tonight my two
favorite restaurants will be going Head
to Head they may be good but do they
have what it takes to go right to the
top
[Music]
to my Nationwide restaurant competition
and so far I found my best Italian
restaurant Casimir from Bristol my best
Indian prashard from Bradford my best
Chinese you and you in Blackburn my best
British the milestone in Sheffield and
my best Thai restaurant Nam Jim from
Saint Andrews
tonight we'll see who will be joining
them in the semi-finals from your
favorite French restaurants
I spent years learning how to cook in
France and I know just how good French
restaurants can be
I'm expecting tonight's contenders to
deliver something really special
remember the piece please Lisa thank you
talk to any Frenchman he'll tell you
they have the best restaurants in the
world but there are lots of British
restaurants serving great French food
for centuries French restaurants have
set the standards in the dining room as
well as in the kitchen a good French
restaurant will wow you with the
elegance and the sophistication of its
Service as well as its food
from nearly a thousand nominations I've
chosen two brilliant French restaurants
to battle it out for a place in my
semi-finals winchingham fields in
Lincolnshire serves stunningly complex
fine dining dishes so beautifully
presented it takes your breath away okay
tutorial away please we know wintering
fields we we live it we breathe it and
it is that nice place where you can sit
down and be treated like a king for a
night batting against them edinburgh's
headed up by a gallic gastronome who
Wows his diners with simple rustic
dishes bursting with flavor second two
goat cheese two Microsoft two beef wait
make it snappy please I'm not cooking
for Kings I'm cooking for simple guys
like me for Country Boys
both my French restaurants are about to
face three formidable challenges
designed to put them under extreme
pressure
first off I've deployed an army of 30
hungry customers who will invade each
restaurant in turn and all order at once
they're on their way to sample the food
on offer at the 16th century manor house
and estate at winchingham fields in
Lincolnshire
what I like most about this place is
it's it's quaint and it's like a little
mini Oasis and also they depend on the
local ingredients stuff produced on
their doorstep and they turn that into
the most amazing food hi guys
I've forgotten how beautiful this place
is amazing amazing amazing
five years ago husband and wife team
Colin and Beck put everything that they
had into this stunning restaurant
so much at stake really and I don't want
to go run fast well Beck takes care of
front of house Colin heads up the
kitchen
space
it's been it's been waiting two minutes
he creates exciting modern dishes
capturing all the Fantastic flavors of
great French cuisine without the
heaviness Lobster risotto I'm excited
about this
delicious
Colin is pulling out all the stops to
put this place on the map the restaurant
boasts a five grand champagne on the
menu one waiter for every two customers
and even has its own helicopter pad
this is the The Landing facilities for
the restaurant we give them the
coordinates and then we just pick them
up yeah they've got all the staff
all the gear the most amazing kitchen
there's obviously a lot of riding on
this you can see it in Colin's face he's
under pressure big time
I'm just under five minutes from now
then my diners will be here and they are
so excited about walking into winter
fields and being blown away you have
dedicated your life to get this place
right really make this count big test
today
two hours 30 of my diners two courses
make sure they leave on cloud nine good
luck
my 30 guests are all looking forward to
being treated and fed like royalty it
should be uh push it together on the
path you know 18.
they're cool we're cool
the Sumptuous dining room screams luxury
a very nice manure for you
Colin quickly serves an amuse Bush not
only will it prepare my guest for the
meal ahead but it also shows off Colin's
expansive approach to cooking
but it's not the only thing that's
expansive
after he left the appetizers he didn't
collect the menu which are quite big you
can't really place it anywhere Jesus
what is that
tell us like this is your life huh when
you know as Amy and Andrews to pop out
from the [__] fireplace we're away
first amuse Bush comes another carrot
moose with coriander ice cream a little
Amish Bush bloody hell will you have
time to get two appetizers and the two
courses in
Jesus you don't do things by half do you
there's a lot going on you know honestly
sometimes less is more
they were delicious but it was quite a
lot of flavors to be served before
you've actually eaten your main meal
perhaps maybe just one would have been
enough
admire Collins Eiffel Tower sized
Ambitions to provide a stunning
gatronomic experience but the minutes
are ticking by and the theatrics show no
sign of giving way to proper food I've
never seen a bread trolley outside the
Humber Bridge this is only big enough
for trolling for a bit yeah it does work
very well really yeah I just watched the
way to push it by it was like banging
left and right
so 30 minutes of gone and we haven't
even taken orders yet I'm not a Fufu man
I'm a flavors man and I want this food
to get out of the kitchen because when
they get to taste this food they'll be
blown away
at last orders have been taken Colin's
menu will do any french Gourmet proud it
includes paper fried Cornish Brie with
muscle and saffron fricassee a beautiful
ham hock and fogart terrine and one of
my favorites John Dory Sir with a beerco
ham and a nollipop sauce
the food's going down a storm but it's
overshadowed by the service
oh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven boo anymore look at all
you guys there seems to be an awful lot
of people I don't think it'd want any
more than the resin here just check
there's no one in here
I don't know I haven't seen the same
person twice yeah
there are three front of house managers
and 12 other waiting staff
what are you doing there I'm just making
sure I just calling for service if you'd
like some tea or coffee no fertilizers
in Heathrow unfortunately just for the
staff Colin that's one hour gone one
hour to go yes okay how long on that
lamp
for his Mains Colin is showcasing his
unique take on the Glorious French
tradition of fine dining he's serving a
delicious rolled saddle of lamb with
polenta chicken cannelloni with foie
gras and an opulent Lobster risotto
accompanied by a Parmesan twill and
lobster bisque
[Music]
system is chaotic with too many people
involved it would be so much better if
just one person took responsibility the
status means desserts and then we have a
little appetizer tick basically the chef
can see it from where he is and
everybody up here knows where they are
up here I'm not convinced despite all
the waiting staff this restaurant's
letting my diners down
we went through May course yes Benoit
guys so it's just one hour 20 minutes
with nothing in front of them all these
waiters are flying around no starters
you're better than that
too Dory too brave it's away now okay
Philly ready service please
as time ticks on everything started to
get muddled up
um which table do you want last table
four and the full scale of the mess is
only just becoming clear oh I've got
terminal four here right are you sure
that's 10 before are you still waiting
on starters
[Music]
unfortunately someone crossed it off at
the top how can you have so many
management out there and they cross it
off and they haven't even sent them yet
huh they've got more managers here
they've got in Buckingham Palace keep
going keep going keep going
with time running out fast and some
guests still not served I'm starting to
feel the worst I say that's it 20
minutes to go Colleen 20 minutes to go
we'll get there about a skin of my life
chicken sauce chicken sauce about five
minutes says [__] let's get it out
three waiters guys last table
[Music]
if you want to someone help him do the
ice cream puts garnish on it
you know but I see the problem is she
probably she's given me that which is
table four and table six right that's it
time out two hours gone
[Music]
incredibly for the first time in this
competition not all my diners have been
fed two courses for a restaurant this
good it's embarrassing
do I want to be judged on a vicious
world or do I want to have that served
in front of me it's a no-brainer it's
beautiful I mean just stunning they
can't tell everybody how [__]
delicious it is because it's gone past
two hours
oh
the only comfort for Colin is the fact
that the diners that did receive their
food loved it it was nice it was well
worth waiting for well worth waiting for
we did wait a little longer than
expected uh and when it came yeah well
worth it once food has arrived we have
forgotten how long we've been waiting
because it is delicious
end of service and time for me to tell
winchingen Fields whether I thought
things were bong or not
feedback from the dining room service
claustrophobic
that's when I pulled some of the waiters
out and get rid of some of the drapes I
think you know that kind of the stayed
you know winching and fields-esque
service can look very I mean everybody
direct feedback back from the customer
experience the service being too
claustrophobic no I appreciate you
listened you ignore it no no not ignore
it are you peril if my diners felt that
your service was claustrophobic please
listen to it because it's valuable
information we're looking for the best
restaurant in Britain not just for the
best food but the best service and it
goes hand in glove
the customers love the food which was
great news sadly didn't get a chance to
taste it all because we ran out of time
don't worry about the Fufu
I think you guys try too hard and I just
think you guys just need to chill
the minute you match the service
with a level of attention detail on the
food you've got something unique here
you've got silent things otherwise it'll
be the [__] [__] next two three
minutes on a palm dolphin please my
diners descend on the garage in
Edinburgh as the battle of the bully
Bays heats up I'm not saying it to make
you look stupid it needs it needs a
leader I'm not asking to just [__] on
your boss
thank you
I'm looking for the nation's best French
restaurants and your nominations have
led me to a fantastic place in Edinburgh
one of the best French restaurants in
Scotland a definite contender in this
competition I fell in love with French
food from a very early age so my
standards are already high and tonight
I'm hoping to be inspired by this
amazing little Bistro
where's the French man where's he hiding
he's hiding
Chef hey golden are you well yeah yeah
good to see you yes this is Jenny nice
to meet you good to see you too hey Chef
Sean Michelle has spent his whole life
cooking in high-end French restaurants
but a decade ago he turned his back on
the world of exclusive oat Cuisine to
open his own restaurant serving No
Nonsense no frails French rustic fair
that remain your form definitely the
style of cooking I wanted to do was
totally different there's nothing to do
with what's being done actually in
restaurant nowadays that's they come
from here come from
I'm not cooking for Kings I'm cooking
for purpose
I'm gonna give a simple guys like me for
Country Boys
Jean-Michel and sous chef Yani serve at
favors like delicious pan-fried scallops
The Bistro classic twice baked Rock 4
souffle and rabbit riettes this
award-winning Bistro has earned its
loyal following yeah that's nice I've
got the texture there it's delicious the
minute you walk through the door of the
Gary you really feel like you're back in
France and that's one of the biggest
compliments I can pay a Frenchman
with food this good combined with
jean-michel's bonami surely my coach
diners can't fail to be seduced
all right
Drive the
kick run the dining room give some
French charm to the service some of the
guests will come in and think that the
rabbit is a little bit intimidating
explain jean-michel's in love with lapan
and he adores rabbit and more
importantly sell it more shorts
here we go
hi there good evening
Russian manager Julie and are all French
front of house team waste no time in
laying on the charm a little English
Bush for you it's spring onions and
cheese Panic can I get up for you thank
you how's the menu sound I'm absolutely
enticing enticing if you have any
question about the rabbit the cook no
problem okay so much two rabbits one
meringue one brioche
orders are starting to come in thick and
fast thank you very much Julie and her
team have done a great job of selling
the rabbit so you got three rabbit
already yeah out of six guests I'll be
over there
I was happy nice Jean-Michel and Julie
have a unique system of communicating
service
Judy did you want me to tell you when
you're ready for the starters in the
main course no just fine just bang what
we really
bang she comes
sounds like a porn movie
how's everybody up there Julie yeah
it's fair upstairs is Buzzy and relaxed
and my diners love the food
[Music]
that's nice
but the kitchen is far too relaxed for
my liking and there are some silly
mistakes occurring is that hot enough is
that it was colder on top
[Music]
One Fish Two llama rabbit
the rabbit's flying out playing huh
let's go for the studio see another
miniature the most popular dish tonight
is the saddle of rabbit with black
pudding and apple that's good to go yeah
the meat's wrapped in fat to baste the
rabbit as it Cooks that's really nice
really good it's all nice it's great to
see Jean-Michel using such a traditional
technique but I'm worried about how he's
running his kitchen
the board is full of checks you're
halfway there yes this is where we're
right up against it right now
Jean-Michel doesn't seem to be taking
the lead in the kitchen leaving both his
Brigade and front of house team
rudderless can't get away from the stove
this one can you no he loves it once he
gets going that's him
I know he loves cooking but with so many
orders on at the same time someone needs
to be taking control are you supposed to
read his mind because he doesn't talk to
me
[Music]
the rabbit's been left under the lights
on the hot plate for two minutes while
Jean-Michel plates up the lamb a rabbit
goes dry within 30 seconds there such a
shame Joey as this is what hurts for me
you've gone from a chef into a cook and
the lamb not ready the rabbit's standing
there
huh
foreign
[Music]
it's not my kitchen so when the rabbit
sits there for two minutes and yannick's
looking at you waiting for a call I just
it needs it needs a leader two three
minutes on a palm door thing please
such a shame
jean-michel's gone from the owner
now into a cook because he's not talking
to anybody next to go pole chef One Fish
Two Line one rabbit thankfully Yannick
has found his voice has sort of started
holding the reins because this place
needs an organizer and someone as a
front runner
I love the way Yanni is tasting
everything he's proven to be the rock in
the Kitchen Tonight hold on two seconds
Audrey Audrey bring that back please I'm
not asking you to [__] on your boss yeah
but when you're standing there slicing
the [__] rabbit has gone dry there's
two lamb to be plated up and he's not
saying anything to you
right next you cook [__] amazing
Foods yeah but I don't understand why
you disappear in service when you you
don't talk to anybody yeah so I'm just
struggling to identify who is the leader
tonight yeah yeah I want to find the
best restaurant in Britain and the best
restaurant in Britain doesn't have food
that sits on the hot plate for two and a
half three minutes
we're on to desserts always a highlight
of great French cuisine true to form
jean-michel's created simple Rusty
desserts including brioche pan Purdue
with apricots Julie I'm so sorry but the
chef check the desserts would you just
run out with them well when he's busy
like that okay he's not busy he's only
two tickets left please show him the
dessert
cursory glance just doesn't do it he
should have tasted them it was quite
tired
it was lovely the brioch today was
absolutely delicious that the apricots
were just too tired okay the apricots
aren't ripe and they should never be
used in the first place
um
[Music]
has a chef seen them an hour ago we
missed nothing going out of your kitchen
whether you're running a bistro fine
dining or a burger store you watch
everything
damn what a shame I'm a bit disappointed
with the with a dessert I think that
separicose could have been much better
there have been serious mistakes in the
Kitchen tonight but what's the verdict
front of house
it's delicious yeah it's the first time
I've ever tried rabbit and so it's
lovely fish was a really meaty wholesome
party yeah I loved it it's fantastic
cheers
time for me to tell legally exactly what
I think
tough night
very tough every restaurant in every
category is going under that level of
scrutiny it's a pressure test
we know as chefs that food shouldn't
hang
for a long time on the hot place I know
I have to take the blade for it I should
have stayed at the past and uh and they
didn't deliver because I know they can
do the job what I did love downstairs
was how often everyone was tasting stuff
so when you run upstairs with apricots
that the chef hasn't tasted I'm gonna
ask you to come back down yeah
and if you tasted those apricots before
they left the hot plate I guarantee you
I said stop we're not serving the
pampered with apricots
apart from that friendly service bloody
good food
thank you thanks very much
like Eric's got great potential
but
it has to be consistent on every plate
whether it's the most amazing starter or
a phenomenal dessert it has to be that
exact standard across every plate and
Jean-Michel has to decide if he wants to
cook all night long then pass the
leadership qualities to his number two
and if he wants to lead then lead he
wants to cook then cook
foreign
[Music]
trip was a massive challenge for
winterfields and leggerig now I'm
inviting both teams to London to discuss
how they're getting on the competition
but what they don't know is that secret
diners sent by me have been to the
restaurants
the first is restaurant critic Simon
Davis I've rigged in with secret cameras
and asked him to be demanding and
difficult I'm allergic to those
I can't eat sultanas
now we'll really see how these
restaurants perform when I'm not there
watching and so will they
first to see the evidence is Colin from
wintingham fields and his sous chef
Slavic
guys how are you big test for you wasn't
it yeah I've never done something like
that before so yeah a bit about your
comfort zone unknown to you you've
actually been tested twice I sent in
my secret Diner
and this is what happened on the coach
trip they let my diners down with over
fussy food and service but have they
learned from their mistakes hi there
thank you very much thank you thank you
we didn't ask for these they just came
to us first off great welcome and these
Bush arrives at the table didn't ask
them gets put down and bang they start
eating uh you'll find three different
menus but only two are available you
have the very first one which is the
lunch menu
and then if you turn the page over
you'll see a red ribbon on the right of
the red we're going to see them when you
surprise that's the one that we only do
in the evening uh yeah okay it will be
screws we have to come back on the left
hand side however you'll find the yellow
cut which is fully available as well we
started the main courses and then you're
trying to do desserts at the back of the
manuscript is in the following page
all right
exhausted the menu is Big imposing huge
descriptions it's long-winded it's
getting heavier and heavier and heavier
and they just want to be left alone
[Music]
right should we get another amuse
Bush that's three things we've had so
far that we haven't ordered you know
beginning to feel like I've really
started to eat now and we haven't had
the first of our three courses I hope
you don't bring us another
one is a really nice gesture great
opener sets the tone for what's
happening next but any more than one and
it looks like you're trying too hard
roasted Lobster that's when the lobster
results
so it was a lobster bisque and the side
the chocolate they have the parmesan
cheese thank you
I was so annoying when he pointed out
that Morale Mushroom I swear his finger
virtually touched the mushroom if not
touched it
I don't know I don't want someone coming
in and pointing their finger over my
feet
[__] her off
food is exquisite you need to look at
your service you need to really just
bring that in and bring a breath of
fresh air in there and you'll surprise
yourself and more importantly attract a
different clientele which you've been
slightly nervous of going for let's go
[Music]
it was great to get feedback from Gordon
it was great for him to say to me you
know it's Gordon Rams are telling you
what's great about your cooking what's
not so good about it and and what to fix
about it and anyone who can say negative
things about it is great because that
means we can analyze it work it do we
need to change it it's great feedback
you know that is priceless
foreign
next will the chef be able to handle the
pressure outside their own kitchens when
you dry that fish a little bit like that
when you come to Sauce it the sauce will
glaze and stick exactly that location
he's uh sourcing the plate like he's
shaking hands of the queen it's going
all over the place
refined French restaurant
winchingenfield from Lincolnshire
service please it's been waiting two
minutes it's battling out with
edinburgh's charming Bistro La garage
to become my best French restaurant
's team Jean-Michel Yani and Julie are
about to discover that one of my spines
has been checking them out I sent in
expert food consultant and cuckoo writer
Sarah Durden Robertson she knows what
makes a great restaurant
hello hello thank you so much for coming
that was a tough test
what you didn't know is that you've
actually been tested twice
when I left the gate I sent in
a secret Diner
let's watch it shall we
my 30 diners Love The garig's Rustic
charm but the service and food suffers
from jean-michel's lack of leadership in
the kitchen are things running more
smoothly now
hello
um table for two Duncan
what would you recommend yeah
when I came here I said I was really
hungry
and she said yes I told the chef that
you were hungry that's very good nice
liaison between the kitchen and the
restaurants good
outside so I don't understand why it's
so hot
[Music]
oh my goodness thank you
oh I'd be delighted it's so hot
ah the man with the power
we should have just asked you
if only I'd known
I've got to set it on
are we not allowed to have that on in
the morning to get the Russian nice and
cool when butter starts melting on the
table are you cutting back on the
electricity bill no no no no no no I
don't know what happened
it's a bit of a Schoolboy era when we
can't have the air conditioning on
or shame
is it too late or could I just have
boiled new potatoes just these are just
a bit batteries just boiled new potatoes
okay thank you
beans are delicious
is that yeah that is that's okay it is
okay okay yeah thank you she's brought
me my placement potatoes
[Music]
I'm talking about the horrible greasy
social potatoes that came out swimming
in fat
they look Dreadful in the kitchen we
have to be to be more
um yeah
you can't do everything you can't do
everything no you can't but when you
cook a stunning main course the garnish
is even as important it boils down to
the consistency again doesn't it
what a shame
I'm a bit worried we're not going to
make it to the airport
days in a doggy bag
oh yes not the ice cream obviously but
yeah yeah because I just think we're not
going to make the flight in time
otherwise sorry that's my fault
[Music]
very much
questions
they do know we're in a wash now we're
ready to go waiting for to come and take
the money she's answered the phone she's
gone off to the kitchen she still hasn't
come to take the money
what a shame right at the very end yeah
dying to get to the flight it's an
urgent request and it's just been
blatantly ignored so it was like sort of
small little niggling facts that you put
them all together it's like a bit of a
below par performance when I know when
that ration's on song it's the best
Bistro in the country
what's up
in a way I'm disappointed by the the
potatoes I got that that's something
that's a lack of concentration a lack of
supervision the service this thing we
can change cooking the potatoes the
communication with the chefs and this
kind of thing can easily be resolved
[Music]
both restaurants have struggled this is
their last chance to impress me
I'm taking the chefs out of their
kitchens and into mine I'm three
Michigan starred restaurant in London
where I'm challenging them to create one
mind-blowing dish
I feel very confident we're a very very
strong team so we are going to work our
bollocks off and it's going to be you
know hopefully a three Mission star
result
[Music]
wow
be in this restaurant this kitchen today
is uh a hell of an experience we're here
to Win It
I want him to raise their game and cook
like they've never cooked before
[Music]
the battle of the French within these
four walls is everything I've ever
wanted ever worked for and I suppose my
dream come true there's no greater
platform for both these restaurants
today to show off only one restaurant go
through the semi-final
make sure it's you and every time you
put food onto that plate think
semi-final
and good luck all the best guys
French cuisine is close to my heart so I
can't wait to see what Jean-Michel and
Colin create using fish as their main
ingredient
first table on they're going four cups
away table five four John Dory please
thank you
but it's not just me they'll have to
impress twenty distinguished guests will
also help me judge both restaurants
dishes
including gioquillo head chef at the
French Embassy and food writer novelist
Johann Harris author of chocolate and
two popular French cookbooks
both restaurants front of house teams
are dining here today and Colin's dad
but they can only sit and wait while
their chefs battle it out and Yannick
give me a time for the first table
please six or seven minutes to the
pasture let's go seven minutes thank you
yanny great love the information
[Music]
have made their names with simple rustic
food but today they're going Hot Cuisine
with post John Dory so with polenta cake
and longest teens a lightly battered
oyster and a longer steam bisque
[Music]
so you run one of the best beach shows
in the country this doesn't sound like a
bistro Classic this sounds like you
we're cooking in your kitchen today we
don't want to do special cooking we try
to raise our camera so you're going uh
you're up there under Europe
so Michelle turned his back ten years
ago I'm trying darning because he wanted
to become a little bit more rustic
but today he's going back to that fine
dining style and he's really pushed the
boat out what he had for breakfast this
morning I don't know it must have been a
[__] strong pot of porridge
Only Hope Jean-Michel and sous chef Yani
aren't over stretching themselves winter
and Fields four red mullet please me
[Music]
Colin give me a time please on the first
table one please okay three minutes on
the four fish please three minutes the
window thank you
on the other side of the kitchen calling
from winchingham Fields usually has the
opposite problem creating food that's
just too fussy
Colin Slavic um exposed because they
haven't got their Entourage of 25 chefs
and 15 gardeners and four you know
individuals to wash their cars so today
they are on their own tonight Collins
pan fried red mullet and serving it with
a bully based sauce and a Mediterranean
salad
the whole idea about this dish is that
it's a salad so each part has to be
perfect and that's what makes the dish
it's not just the flavors you can show
off you can show off courgette some
green beans so it's good
okay how integral is it on a scale of
one to ten see the garnish is going to
be about seven out of ten the rest of it
four wow it's not bad for you is it I
know yeah
listening listening because d
constructing a nicoise salad in this way
is a bold move now he's got rid of all
the distraction Thrills Colin's gonna
have to really focus on flavors to make
this work I thought Colin on Winston
Phil's doesn't go more complicated over
the top yeah he's reigned it in he's
he's gone simpler it's a chance to
concentrate and really really show off
over at lagerig the timing of their
polenta and deep-fried oyster must be
perfect
to disappear in your mouth it's pretty
Sage cooking just check your place a
little bit of water there work together
just try to drain that fish next time in
the cloth when you dry that fish a
little bit like that when you come to
Sauce it the sauce will glaze and stick
exactly that yeah wait what's the sauce
in the room of the plates
as they plate up the pressure has
clearly taking its toll
sauce in the plate like he's uh shaking
hands of the queen it's going all over
the place
it's a shame because he looks nervous
which I didn't expect especially if I'm
a Frenchman
start to shaking it'll be shaking my
life you know even when I got married
there was no shaking you know the girl
that made me shake you know it's
incredible
I'll get the oysters in you start
plating
happy with that ship that's absolutely
beautiful Chef yeah perfect in
jean-michel's hour of need I'm delighted
to say that sous chef Yani is stepping
up to the plate again I love the way
you're tasting as well yes yeah what
you're tasting yeah is what they're
eating yes let's go go last table now
please yeah two John Dory away table
three please
fish good to go hello good to go this is
good to go let's go Jean-Michel and
Yanni are really working as a team
sending out plate after plate of
exquisite looking food John Michelle
they look great fantastic very let's go
please no time to the plate well done
excellent go double four please
[Music]
thank you coach John Dory and
langoustein Cake oyster Beignet on top
and a lobster bisque
it's very delicate it's an explosion
table four four more away please on
table five yes and keep that momentum
going guys please yes Colin's gone for a
simple dish so he's cooking must rely on
flavors not frails and I'm not sure he's
nailed it before you pass that it tasted
fragrant and like a like Bully base
although it's almost like it's fishing
so it's done more veggies you want it to
taste but what's on there I'll fish
exactly yeah fine okay
today they have to make sure that dish
is all about Flavor not how things look
let's have a how long please 10 seconds
fish 10 seconds
work together come on guys
jelly check your plates nice come on
wait we're together we're together once
together yeah vibrant colors love the
idea of the egg yolk on there let's go
good happy with those Colin wee Chef
yeah they look fantastic go table one
please go beautiful I love that level of
creativity and the confidence to be that
simple without red mullet brilliant
last time we just make it look
absolutely perfect like the first hour
yes okay great table three please let's
go oh sorry sorry sorry
thank you very much
Colin get over every one of your dishes
yes
good okay thank you cool excellent okay
pan fried red mullet you have tomato
fondue courgettes I finish with potato
on top
quotation is brilliant and I'd expect
nothing less but I hope his dish is as
successful as leguiz
beautiful that involves a little bit of
skill to get something out that's still
sizzlingly crispy as well
foreign service is over and it's time to
find out which of these two incredible
dishes my guests preferred starting with
winchingham Fields
nice to see you
excellent now let's talk fish um red
mullet how was it really nice
you really like when it's Christmas
and what do you think of the sauce I
love that
yeah it's really good
summertime and yeah it's really simple
and I really like it I thought the red
mullet was absolutely fantastic and when
it came out the skin was really nice and
crispy and it was still very fresh and
hot from the pan it was like being in
the Mediterranean you know on a sunny
day sunshine on a play
the fish was slightly overcooked for me
but overall uh it was a really good dish
ladies let's talk John Dory how was it
on the whole I think it was very nice
good the whole balance of the dish was
beautiful and the flavors were very
complementary to each other we all found
I think that the oyster was a slightly
odd thing because we couldn't quite tell
what it was yeah interesting Johnny Dory
I loved the um love the fish and really
delighted by the oyster I thought that
was a real treat
[Music]
both French teams have excelled
themselves in my kitchen serving up
Exquisite food worthy of their
reputations and mine
I think to go through the semi-finals
would be it would be excellent for the
restaurant for everyone back in
Edinburgh all the staff we've worked
with I think it would be a dream come
true for us all we'll see what the
printers are thinking
and then we'll take it from there I was
happy with everything that went out
there was nothing I wasn't happy with
each individual part was cooked that I
wanted to be cooked so everything went
out I'm happy
now I must decide which team has their
all-important je ne sais quoi to take
them through to the semi-final
[Music]
the chefs from my top two French
restaurants Colin from Winchester fields
in Lincolnshire and Jean-Michel from
legaric in Edinburgh have just finished
the service of their lives
two exceptional restaurants but only one
can stay in the competition
me choose I'm going to taste each team's
dish
[Music]
visually both dishes look attractive
great finesse
so let's read first this guy surprised
me today
polenta lined inside with longestine
ambitious and dangerous
hmm
tastes very good
John Dory
sauce is delicious Rich robust and a
really nice sort of shellfish bisque
really good
doesn't need the oyster fried at the end
not really no the sauce is the is the
key there
I love hearts true French passion all
over that plate
Fields red mullet
crisp you can hear it as we cut across
beautiful
hmm
delicious packed full of flavor I've
been taking part there is the sauce it's
like a sort of tomato bully base bisque
very clever
and it looks
intricate but it is very very simple
and bloody delicious this is a tough
call because it really surprised me and
I'm more surprised with Jean-Michel
because I didn't think he had the
capability of doing that and I didn't
think that Colin could Reign it in
two outstanding French restaurants but
only one can win a place in the
semi-finals
[Music]
okay
the winner today
is based on everything we've experienced
Colin
you pulled it back you sort of rained it
in which I didn't expect to see today
that dish
delicious
excelling is difficult under pressure
but you push the boat out
think of the journey
and we started off with 30 diners
turning up unexpectedly
for any restaurant anywhere in the
country that is immense pressure I mean
really immense pressure
both rations handle it brilliantly well
after that I then secretly filmed your
restaurants in operation
unknown to any of you
to make sure that you weren't just
rolling out the red carpet because it
was me
and that told me a lot
so
based on everything I've seen
everything I've eaten and everything
I've experienced
the winner is going to come down to this
the restaurants that I want to go back
to is it the legary that French charm
that real come in sit in my front room
with an Ambiance that is electric
or is it the Sumptuous wrestling with
rooms that you walk in and you're sort
of Blown Away with that charm
tough
the winner
of the French category
[Music]
it's windicum fields
hello
congratulations
Jean-Michel you surprised me today and
you are a credit not just to your
restaurant but your country because you
showed flashes of brilliance don't stop
well done
well done well done I'll be disappointed
that at the same time I'm very pleased
with what we've done today I'm going to
take it back to ragarig and take it from
there and start again
high five
great result for us which I'm really
chuffed to bits with Gordon Ramsay one
of the most famous chefs in the world um
telling me that you know he likes my
food and he wants to go back to my
restaurant so yeah how big do you get on
top of that you know it's fabulous so
yeah we're really really just a bit
[Music]
forever
I've been on the most amazing journey of
these two French restaurants and it's
quite sad to say goodbye to the garig
however the journey Starts Now for
Winston Fields they so deserve their
place in the semi-final